I don't trust anything to hold these
edges so really I just you know kind of
beyond saying it I woke up like this
the main thing I know about this gel is
that it is called Gorillaz not very
aggressive marketing I know very little
about it other than its supposed to be
like a really strong hold people use
this gel for very like extreme
hairstyles like a mohawk we're like a
punk so apparently I'm supposed to try
some really great gel that's gonna slay
these edges I don't trust it this is a
lot of hair and I'm gonna need a lot of
hold we got some goob action going on
here
it looks like snot clearly I don't know
how much I'm supposed to use a little
worried even the first amount is gonna
be too much
it's like tacky the longer I put it on
and so it is white I can tell it's
starting to hold I don't know if this is
this is for my hair type this is
obviously I think gonna be more of like
like a wet look like a like a slick look
it looks like how I definitely hate my
hair when it looks wet holds but in a
different way it's like 90% there I
think this will work really well on like
a twist out or a wash and go like
something where you're actually trying
to style it I think I need to be around
a 2 on the hold meter and I'm on a 10
right now I feel like there's kind of
like a slick sheen kind of vibe that
like this could be like a good night
life Joe I'm gonna say that it's not my
style because it's very very shiny and
that wet look that I don't go for but I
would give it a try I'm gonna go
throughout the day see how it holds up
but I'm confident I'm confident that a
whole
it just looks kind of wetter to me right
now it's hard feels hard I don't know if
this is what I want so it looks like the
general consensus is that it's crispy or
looking but not really all that
different I will say that it held up
well the rep that it gets for holding
its grip is legit okay so I'm not mad
about this product like he didn't flake
up my edges the little curls that did
pop up are like shiny mean it didn't
flake but this isn't something you can
just slap when I go like you definitely
would need a brush or a satin scarf
virtually I'm not having the best
experience but honestly I do believe if
I had a hairdryer it would have looked
fine and perfect I've had this hairstyle
for a while with the moko Loogootee
Liddell and to be honest I'm not as mad
as I thought I would be it's not a hair
gel I would use every single day but if
an occasion comes and I need something
stronger I know what's used now
[Music]